[Music]
channing tatum and zoe kravitz keep
sparking romance rumors
i don't know what you're even talking
about
here are the stars shopping together on
monday leaving a supermarket in upstate
new york
zoe is holding red roses while channing
pushes a shopping cart next to her
and this is just the latest snapshot of
the rumored couple they've been
photographed together multiple times in
the past week
they were first spotted together earlier
this month when the duo went for a bike
ride together around new york city
the supermarket outing also follows an
eyewitness report from last week when
e.t learned the two took a walk together
in nyc's east village
the source told et that channing and zoe
seemed very relaxed and were smiling and
laughing during their stroll
so what's the scoop on these two
we can only speculate at the moment but
we do know this rumored romance follows
zoe's split with ex-husband carl
glussman their divorce was finalized on
wednesday
the big little lie star initially filed
for divorce back in december the couple
tied the knot in july 2019 after three
years of dating as for channing he's
starring in zoe's directorial debut a
movie thriller that she also co-wrote
and channing he seems to be everywhere
this month yeah i agree with that last
week he shared this behind-the-scenes
moment to instagram
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
yep that's channing picking up sandra
bullock and jumping into a pool
the fun moment came shortly after the
co-stars wrapped their latest project
the lost city of d
all right everybody
[Music]